Last time I invited you to think about life on the experience of machine where
the scientists so busy stimulating your brain in such a ways to give you an
exact replica from the insides of what it would be like.
You're having an identical experiences.
So the ones you would have if you were really doing well,
whatever it is,
it's worth doing.
You know,
climbing the Alps off,
writing the great American novel,
uh,
raising a great family that you know,
that loves you being creative,
whatever it is,
you think it's worth.
Having the experience machine gives you all the experiential side of those
things,
but you're not really doing those things.
You're actually just floating in the scientist's lab and we ask ourselves,
would you want to live a life on the experience machine?
Would you be happy or would you be unhappy to discover that you actually have
been living a life on the experience machine?
Most of us,
when we think about this,
find ourselves wanting to say no,
we wouldn't want to have a life on the experience machine.
I,
I've been discussing this sort of example for many,
many years and there's always a group of people who think,
yes,
life on the experience machine is perfect as long as we've got the right tape
plane.
But the vast majority always says no.
There's something missing from that life.
It's,
it's not the ideal of human existence.
It's not the best possible life we can imagine ourselves having.
That means if we think something's missing,
we didn't have to ask ourselves what's missing?
What's wrong with the experience machine?
The one thing we can conclude immediately is if you think life on the experience
machine is missing something that the hedonist and views like hedonism must be
wrong in so far as they say,
that all that matters for the best possible life is wellbeing for wellbeing is
getting the right kinds of experiences,
getting the right kinds of mental states,
because by hypothesis,
the experience machine gets the mental states right,
gets the insides right.
So if something's missing from that life,
there's more to the best kind of life than just having the right mental states
than just getting the insides right.
Well,
we ask ourselves then,
well,
what's missing?
I think different people will answer that in different ways and if we had more
time we could spell out rival theories of wellbeing,
which could be interestingly sort of a distinguish one from another in terms of
how they answered the question,
what's missing from the experience machine on the one hand and why are the
things that are missing from the experience machine worth having different
theories of wellbeing might answer that in different ways instead of trying to
pursue those alternative theories in a systematic fashion.
Let me just gesture towards some of the things that seem to be missing from that
kind of life.
Well,
first of all,
most perhaps,
obviously if you're just spending your life floating in the scientist's lab,
you're not actually accomplishing anything.
You're not actually getting the things out of life you thought you were getting.
You want it to be climbing the mountain,
but you're not actually climbing a mountain.
You're just floating there.
You want it to be writing the great American novel,
but you're not writing the great American novel.
You're just floating there.
You want it to be finding a cure for cancer,
but you're not actually finding a cure for cancer.
You want it to be loved,
but you're not actually loved.
You're just floating there and nobody other than the scientist even knows that
you exist.
So there's a,
a variety of things you wanted.
You wanted to know your place in the universe,
but you don't even have that kind of knowledge either because you think you're
writing novels,
finding the cure for cancer,
climbing Mount Everest,
you completely deceived about all of those things.
So you don't have the kind of self knowledge that many of us value.
Well,
as they say,
different theories would try to systematize these examples in different ways,
uh,
that we don't have any kinds of accomplishments.
We don't have knowledge,
we're not in the right kinds of loving relationships.
Different theories might have different explanations as to are these things
valuable because we want them or do we walk them because we recognize their
valuable rather than trying to pursue those questions and indeed trying to work
out the details of these dudes to be complicated as well.
Uh,
take,
take the example of accomplishment.
Well,
we all think accomplishments important,
but it's not as though any old accomplishment is important.
Uh,
if somebody sets himself or,
so it seems to me at least if somebody sets their self the goal of making the
biggest rubber band ball,
uh,
in the eastern United States,
I suppose there's a sense of the word that that's an accomplishment if they've
got it.
But it doesn't strike me as the kind of accomplishment which makes for a
particularly valuable life.
So they might have to distinguish between any old accomplishment and genuinely
valuable accomplishments.
But again,
just put those details aside.
We can say that there are certain things that are good above and beyond
experiences,
the right kinds of accomplishments,
the right kind of knowledge after all,
not every bit of knowledge is equally valuable.
It's one thing to know your place in the universe.
So to know the fundamental laws of physics,
it's another thing to know what was the average rainfall in Bangkok in 1984,
not clear.
That kind of knowledge gives a whole lot of value to your life.
So,
so we need the right kinds of accomplishments and the right kind of knowledge
and the right kinds of relationships.
But imagine you've worked that out.
The crucial point is that it takes more to have the best kind of life than just
getting the insides right.
It also requires getting the outside's right,
whatever that comes to having in your life.
Not just experiences but the right kinds of goods or accomplishments or whatever
term we use for it.
Now they say,
instead of pursuing the questions of how exactly that theory should go,
notice that if we had that theory,
we could still evaluate in principle whatever the practical difficulties might
be.
In principle,
we could still evaluate rival lives.
We could talk about adding up all the positive experiences along with all the
ask is of how many goods,
how many accomplishments of the of the right sort.
We're in that life and that's on the positive side of the ledger and against
that,
we would then have to subtract the sum total of the negative experiences,
all the failures and deceptions or what have you.
Those would count against the overall value of your life.
We could still say it's how good your life is as a matter of adding up the goods
and subtracting the bads,
but we now have a somewhat broader or more encompassing or inclusive list of
goods and more broad and encompassing list of Bads,
not just experience,
but also these various other accomplishments,
whatever.
Exactly that list comes to so we could still evaluate rival lives.
My life would have gone better if I had I chosen to become a farmer instead of
chosen to become a doctor or my life would have gone better for this period of
10 years,
but then would have become worse or what have you,
or when we ask ourselves how will things go for me over the next couple of weeks
if I,
if I go on vacation versus staying back here,
we add up the goods,
subtract the bads,
whatever our favorite list is and we come to the our best educated guess about
the rival evaluations of not just lives as a whole but chunks of lives.
Now what are those totals come to?
Well,
you might think it's an empirical question and in fact I am,
I'm inclined to think it's an empirical question varying from person to person,
but it's worth taking a moment to flag the fact that there are people,
there are philosophers who think we can generalize across all humans.
You might say that optimists are people who think that for everybody,
in every case,
in every circumstance,
the totals always positive.
Life's always worth living.
It's always better than non existence.
That's what the optimist thinks,
not just for themselves individually,
but for everybody.
That totals always positive against that.
I suppose you've got pet pessimists,
pessimists to say no,
no.
Although life perhaps has some good things,
the overall grand balance is negative for everybody.
In every circumstance.
We'd all be better off dead or perhaps more accurately,
still all be better off never having been born in the first place.
That's what the pessimists say.
And,
and in between the optimists,
on the one hand,
the pessimists on the other,
you've got moderates,
uh,
who say,
look,
it varies in and,
and for some people they'll let the balance is positive.
For some people,
perhaps the balance has negative,
whether for their life as a whole or for certain stretches of their lives.
We then have to get down to facts about cases.
Try to describe the instance,
perhaps somebody who's in the terminal stages of some illness,
whether they're in a great deal of pain and the various other external goods of
life,
they can't because they're bedridden.
They can own longer,
accomplish things,
perhaps their families abandoned them.
W whatever the details might be,
we could describe lives and say whether or not their life was good as a whole.
The what,
what,
what sort of their future holds out for them,
uh,
is negative.
That's what the,
the moderate would say.
It varies from case to case.
Well,
however we settled that issue.
Notice there's still one other assumption that all these,
uh,
positions have still still have in common.
We've,
we've expanded our list of goods so that nobody's going to deny that among the
goods of life are our pleasure and other positive experiences and among the bads
of life,
our pain and other negative experiences.
But we've expanded the list of goods.
So it includes external goods and not only experiential or internal goods.
Still the views that I've been sketching all still have the following assumption
in common.
How good it is to be alive is a matter of adding up all of the call it the
contents of life,
add up your experiences and your accomplishments and the the particular,
the particular details of your life as what the story's about.
It's it's as though we've been assuming and tech I have been assuming up to this
moment that being alive per se has no value.
It's life itself is a container which we feel with various goods or bads and and
deciding how valuable it is,
how good it is for me to be alive as a matter of adding up the value of the
contents of the life,
but the container itself is a mirror container.
It has no value in and of itself.
We could say that.
What I've been presupposing up to this point is the neutral container theory of
the value of life hedonisms a version of the neutral container theory.
How valuable,
how well off you are,
how valuable your life is.
Is a is a function of the contents,
the pleasure in the pain.
We've expanded the list of goods that can go within your life.
But for all that we still been acting as though the neutral container theories,
the right approach.
But against this there are those who think no,
and in addition to thinking about the value of the content of life,
we have to remember so these people claim that life itself is worth having.
There's,
there's a benefit to me above and beyond the question of what's going on with in
my life.
Am I loved?
Am I accomplishing things?
Am I having nice experiences,
are not above and beyond the question of the contents of my life.
We have to remember that the mere fact that I'm alive gives my life some value.
So these are valuable container theories.
Now think about what it would mean to accept a valuable container theory.
You're saying that being alive per se has some positive value.
Oh,
actually,
first remark is probably wouldn't be completely accurate to say to describe
these views.
I was saying it's been alive per se.
After all,
a blade of grass is alive and,
and I presume that even fans of the,
what we might call malleable container theories don't think that,
oh,
wouldn't it be wonderful if as long as I was alive in the way that a blade of
grass is alive,
life may have value in and of itself.
But if not mere life,
what we want is the life of,
of a human.
We want a life in which we're,
we're accomplishing things.
There's agency and the life of knowing things cause you didn't have to be a
knower in order to have knowledge.
The life of somebody who can have an emotional side.
So it's something like the life of a person.
When we say when there are people who are inclined to say that being alive per
say is valuable,
presumably what they mean is being alive as a person per se is valuable.
All right.
Note that point.
Keep it in mind for simplicity.
I'll talk about these abuses.
Are they say life per se is valuable?
Actually,
I suppose there could be a more extreme view still.
I,
it seems implausible to me,
but I suppose it's worth noticing.
There are people who think no being alive per se,
right?
Even though there I am and my and my,
my brain has been so thoroughly destroyed that I'm no longer able to know
anything,
no longer able to relate emotionally to anybody,
no longer able to accomplish anything.
There I am just in a,
in a persistent vegetative state,
but at least I'm alive.
You could imagine somebody who has that view.
We've got to say,
I find that a pretty implausible view,
so I'm going to restrict myself at least when I think about it,
to versions that say it's the life of a person per say.
That's valuable.
Now,
now notice that if we accept this view to decide how well off I am or somebody
else is,
you can't just add up the contents of the life.
You can't just add up all the pleasures and subtract the pains or add up all the
accomplishments and subtract the failures or add up all the knowledge and
subtract the the ignorance and deception.
Doing that in terms of the contents gives you a subtotal,
but that sub subtotal is no longer the entire story because we also have to add
in if we accept a valuable container theory,
we also have to add in some extra positive points to take account of the fat
that well,
at least you're alive or have the life of a person or whatever it is that you
think is valuable in and of itself.
So first we get the content subtitle subtotal,
then we add some extra points for the mere fact that you're alive.
Now notice that since we're adding extra positive facts,
extra positive points for the fact that you're alive.
Okay.
Even if the contents subtotal is negative,
the grand total could still be positive.
I suppose being alive per se is worth plus a hundred points just to make up some
number.
Even if your content sub total was negative 10 that doesn't mean you're not
better off a lot because negative 10 plus the extra hundred points for the mere
fact that you're alive still going to give you a positive total plus 90
yeah,
so the,
the,
the point of thinking about the possibility of accepting a valuable container
theory is to remind us that in deciding,
you know,
you're better off dead has,
has death deprived me of something good or not.
It's important to not just focus on the contents but to also remember to add
some positive points above and beyond just the content subtotal to take into
account the value of the sheer fact that you're alive.
If you're a fan of the neutral container theory,
you won't have anything extra to add.
Cause life per se is just a zero.
It's strictly a matter of the contents.
But if you accept to valuable container theory,
you have to add something more.
And so even if you might say,
the way my life is going in terms of its contents is bad,
being alive per se might still be a good thing.
I have to add some extra points.
How much extra?
Well,
here we're going to have of course,
more modest and more bold versions of the valuable container theory.
Let me just distinguish two broad types,
what we might call modest versions of the valuable container theory.
Say,
although being alive per se is good.
If the contents of your life get bad enough,
that can outweigh the value of being alive so that the grand total is negative.
Modest container theories that is say there's value to being alive,
but it can in principle be outweighed whether it gets outweighed easily or
whether it's very,
very difficult and the contents have to be horrible to outweigh it depending on
how much value you think being alive per se has.
So those are modest theories,
positive value for life,
but it can be outweighed against that.
You could imagine somebody who thinks being alive per se is so incredibly
valuable that no matter how horrible the contents are,
the grand total will always be positive.
It's,
it's as though being lives,
it is infinitely valuable.
In comparison to questions about the contents.
We could call this the fantastic valuable container theory as opposed to the
modest valuable container theory.
I suppose that label gives away where I want to come down on this.
I find the the fantastic valuable container theory.
Fantastic in the sense of sort of incredible.
I can't,
I can't bring myself to believe it,
which
I have some sympathies for valuable container theories were also have some
sympathy for neutral container theories.
Sometimes I'm drawn towards the neutral view.
Sometimes I'm drawn to her.
The thought that being alive per se is good for you,
but even in those moments when I'm drawn towards valuable container theories,
it's always the modest version.
I don't find myself drawn towards the fantastic version.
Now,
if we,
if we make these distinctions,
then again,
remembering that the question we've been asking ourselves is,
you know,
so why is death bad?
The deprivation account says death is bad for you in so far as,
or it's bad for you when,
what?
By virtue of dying now what you've been deprived of his,
you know,
another chunk of life that would have been good for you to have.
And what we now see is that to see whether that could be the case or not,
we've got to get clear in our own minds about whether we believe in a neutral
container theory,
uh,
a positive valuable theory or and among those between a fantastic and a modest
container theory.
If we are neutral lists,
we're going to say the question is what would the contents of my life have been,
you know,
for the next year,
10 years,
whatever.
If that would have been worth having,
then if as the next chunk of my life would have been worth having,
then it's bad for me that I die now instead of living for the next 10 years.
On the other hand,
if the balance from here on out would have been negative,
then it's good for me that I died now instead of being kept alive with a life
not worth living.
That's how the neutralist put it.
If we are valuable containers,
theorists,
we think the answer's got to be,
well look at the contents,
but don't forget to add some extra points.
Even if the next five years for you would have been in terms of the contents,
you know modestly bad.
Perhaps the value of at least being alive at all outweighs it so it still would
have been better for you to be alive.
But if the contents get bad enough then you'd be better off dead.
Noticing that on the modest view,
if we ask ourselves would it had been good to be immortal,
the answer is going to depend on not just whether we accept Bernard Williams,
his claim that immortality will be bad for you because we now realize that what
Williams was talking about was the contents of an immortal life and that's no
longer an adequate view.
At least it's no longer a complete story.
If we are valuable container theorists,
we could say,
you could imagine somebody saying,
Oh yes,
you're right Williams,
the contents get negative,
but that's still outweighed by the mere fact that you're alive.
So unbalanced being a mortal is a good thing.
Whether that's right or not depends on just how bad would it be to be immortal
because of course,
if you're a modest,
if you accept the modest version of the valuable container theory,
then if the contents get bad enough,
that can outweigh the positive value of life against that.
Fans of the fantastic valuable container theory can say it doesn't really matter
whether it Williams is right,
even if being a mortar will become horrendously boring and tedious or worse,
doesn't matter.
The value of being alive per se outweighs that.
So you're always better off being alive so more life would always be better,
no matter how horrible the contents might be.
So being immortal really would be a good thing for you.
Death always is a bad thing.
That's what you can say if you accept the fantastic container theory.
I don't find a fantastic container theory of myself.
I don't find it particularly attractive.
I'm inclined to think not only that,
not only that the contents of life would be bad eventually for all of us if we
were mortal,
but that would be bad enough to outweigh whatever value,
whatever positive value being alive per se may have for us.
So I'm inclined to think eventually in mortality would always be bad over
all
right.
But let me remind you that saying that does not rule out the possibility of
consistently going on to say that even though it's a good thing that we die
because eventually in mortality would be horrible for all that death could still
come too soon.
It could still be the case that we die before life has turned bad.
We die.
While it's still the case that Lilly in another 10 years or 20 years or for that
matter of 500 years would still or could still have been good for us.
It's compatible with thinking that immortality,
it would be bad to think that in fact,
death comes too soon.
But of course
we now have a return of the division between moderates,
optimists,
and pessimists might say,
optimists are those now,
this more chasing version of optimism.
Optimists say,
even if in mortality would be bad eventually after a million years or 10 million
years or what have you,
you know,
that next chunk of life would have been good for all of us.
So that death,
they're optimist in this strange sense and I think life would have been good,
which means of course,
that that we die is bad for us because we all die too soon.
That's what the optimists might say against that.
The pessimists might say,
boy,
death comes not a moment too soon for any of us.
The next chunk of life is always not worth having.
Always worse than nothing.
And in between these two extremes are the moderates who say,
for some of us,
death comes too soon for some of us death and does not come too soon.
There's a quote,
I want to read it.
It's,
it's actually out of,
out of place now.
I should have read it,
uh,
you know,
a lecture or two ago when I started talking about immortality,
but I misplaced it.
So I found it this morning.
So before we just leave the subject of and mortality,
let me conclude with some words of wisdom from a former Miss USA contestant.
She was asked the question,
you know,
would you want to live forever?
And she responded,
I would not live forever because we should live forever.
Because if he were supposed to live forever,
then we would live forever.
But we cannot live forever,
which is why I would not live forever.
Isn't that nice?
All right.
So I've been talking for actually now a couple of weeks I suppose about the
central badness of death.
Why is it the death is bad for me.
And the answer I've proposed is the deprivation account,
this central bad thing about the fact that I'm going to die is the fact that
because I'll be dead,
I'll be deprived of the good things in life.
And we've now seen that that's a bit crude,
right?
We have to not talk,
just talk about the good things in life.
But the good of life itself and we have to notice that perhaps on certain views
for certain cases.
It's not really the case that when I die I'm being deprived of a good life
because my,
the next chunk or perhaps from there on out it would have been bad,
but still details and complications of the sort we've been considering aside the
fundamental badness of death is that it deprives me of life worth having.
But although I'd been at pains to say that this is the fundamental bad thing
about death,
I think it's arguable that I think that one could make the case that this isn't
the only bad thing about death.
Even if we're focusing on why his death bad for me,
there are other features of death as we experience it that are separable from
the deprivation account that at least add to the way that death occurs for us,
where we didn't have to ask the question,
does this add to the badness of death or,
or conceivably for some of these things,
perhaps it,
it mitigates it,
it,
it minimizes it in in one way or another.
So I want to do is take at least a couple of minutes,
uh,
and pursue some of these extra features as well.
Here's an example.
It's not merely the fact that it's not merely true that that you're going to
die.
It's inevitable that you're going to die there.
No avoiding the fact that you're going to die.
And I look,
you know,
you're all going to college,
but it wasn't inevitable that you go to college.
Had you,
had you chosen not to,
you could have avoided going to college,
but it doesn't matter what you choose,
you can't avoid dying.
So it's not just merely the case that in fact we are all going to die.
It's unnecessary truth that we're all going to die.
So we might ask,
what about this inevitability of death?
Does that make things worse?
And here I wanted to distinguish between the individual question about the
inevitability of death and the universal question.
So just start by thinking about the fact that it's unavoidable,
that you're going to die.
Does the unavoidability of death make it better or worse?
And the interesting thing is I think you can see,
you can get a feel for both possible answers here.
On the one hand,
you could imagine somebody who says,
look,
it's bad enough that I'm going to die,
but the fact that there's nothing I could do about it just makes it worse.
It's like adding insult to injury that I'm powerless in the face of death.
I cannot escape the grim reaper.
This sheer powerlessness about the central fact about the nature of my existence
is an extra insult added to the injury.
Okay?
Against that.
However,
there are those people who'd want to say,
no.
Actually,
the inevitability of my death reduces the badness.
Y'All know there especially,
you know,
don't cry over spilled milk,
right?
That what's done is done.
You can't change it.
What you can't change,
sort of lose it when you,
when you focus on the fact that you can't change it,
it loses some of its grip to upset you.
Well,
if that's right.
And if we then realize that there's nothing I can do about the fact that I'm
going to die,
then perhaps some of the sting,
some of the bite,
uh,
is,
is eliminated.
It's as though you try,
try getting upset about the fact that that two plus two equals four.
You know,
try,
try feeling upset at your powerlessness to change the fact that two plus two
equals four.
You know,
it's supposed to,
you,
you wanted to plus two to equal five,
you know,
can,
can you work up,
you know,
anger and regret and dismay over that.
Most of us,
of course can't because when we see that something is just necessary,
we,
it,
it reduces the,
the,
the sting of it.
The philosopher Spinoza thought that if we could only recognize the fact that
what he at least took to me,
the fact that everything that happens in life is necessary,
then we'd get a kind of emotional distance from it.
Are no longer upset us.
We could no longer be disappointed because to be disappointed in something
presupposes that it could have been some other way.
And spinosa thought,
if you see that it couldn't go any other way,
then you be sad about it.
Well,
if we see that our death is inevitable and we really internalize that fact,
perhaps that would reduce the badness of it.
Oh,
maybe that's right.
But going back to the firsthand,
I don't know how many of you read Dostoyevsky's a,
a short novel,
the underground man,
the underground man is upset about the,
if I remember correctly,
he's upset about the fact that two plus two equals four and there's nothing that
he can do about it.
He started,
he curses,
existence,
curses God,
that having made him so impotent that he can't change the fact that two plus two
equals four and,
and another philosopher Descartes,
and thinking about Dodd's omnipotence thought that it wouldn't be good enough if
God as omnipotent couldn't change the facts of mathematics.
And so he imagines that God as that Putin could have made two plus two equals
five.
And so it's a kind of,
so it is indeed a fact of our powerlessness that we're stuck with the
necessities.
God isn't stuck with them.
And so just to escape takes that thought and runs with it and says,
yeah,
it doesn't help to say that it's inevitable.
It makes it worse.
You know,
there's both sides.
And as I say,
I myself can in different moods get pulled in both ways.
What about the fact that not only is it inevitable that I'm going to die,
it's inevitable that we're all going to die.
Does the universality of death make things better or worse?
And again,
you can,
you can sort of feel,
feel the pool both ways.
On the one hand you say,
look,
it's bad that I'm going to die,
but I'm not a monster.
Makes me feel even worse than everybody else's stuck,
dying.
Or perhaps we should say dying too soon.
In light of our discussion about in mortality,
it's a pity that most everybody,
or perhaps everybody dies too soon.
That makes it even worse.
On the other hand,
you know,
let's be honest here,
we also know the expression misery loves company.
Uh,
and there's at least some comfort to be had,
isn't there in the realization that this,
this,
this thing isn't just true for me.
It's not like the universe has singled me out for the deprivation of dying too
soon.
Uh,
it's something that it does to everybody.
So perhaps there's some comfort in the inevitability of death.
Well,
here's a different aspect of death.
We're thinking about what about the variability of death after all,
it's not just the case that we all die and,
and I'll stop saying die too soon.
Let's just suppose we understand that clause to be implied in what I'm saying.
It's not just the case that we all die.
There's a deal of variation in how much life we get.
Some of us make it to the ripe old age of 80,
90,
a hundred or more.
Others of us die at 20 or 15 or 10 or younger.
Okay.
Even if death were inevitable,
it wouldn't have to come in different size packages.
That is,
it wouldn't have to have variability.
We could imagine a world in which everybody dies.
Everybody dies at the age of a hundred.
Does it make things worse or better that there's this kind of variability
from a moral point of view?
I suppose it's fairly straight forward.
Just suggest it makes things worse.
After all,
most of us are inclined to think that any quality is morally objectionable.
It's bad that through no fault of their own,
some people are poor and other people are rich,
while other people are rich.
If any is morally objectionable,
then it's very likely we're gonna think it's Mora morally horrendous that
there's this crucial inequality.
Some of us die at the age of five while others get to live to 90
but in keeping with the focus of our discussion about the badness of death,
they want to put aside the moral question and think about how good or bad for me
is it that there's variability in death?
Well,
we might say,
let's,
let's look at it from,
from two basic perspectives.
Those who get less than the average lifespan and those who get more than the
average lifespan.
From the point of view of somebody who gets less,
this is obviously a bad thing.
It's bad enough that I'm going to die too soon.
Said I wasn't going to keep saying that remark and Ari,
I'm saying it anyway.
It's bad enough that I'm going to die,
but what's even worse is I'm going to get even less than the average amount of
life.
That's clearly an extra bad,
but we might then wonder,
look for every person who gets less than the average amount of life.
Yeah,
at least supposed to take the media and take the amount of life.
That's exactly.
50% of the people get more.
50% of people get less.
For every person who has less than the median amount of life,
there's another person who has more than the median amount of life.
That person gets to say,
Hey,
well,
you know,
it's a pity they didn't go on to die or die too soon,
but at least I'm getting more than the average.
That's a plus.
So perhaps these two aspects balanced themselves out.
You know,
there are people who were basically screwed by the fact that they get less than
the average amount and people who are benefited by getting more than the average
amount.
So perhaps in terms the individual badness of death,
that's a wash maybe except seems to me it's a further fact about human
psychology that we care more about being short changed then we do about being as
we might put it over compensated.
I rather suspect that people who have less than the average of something,
it hurts them more than it benefits the people who have more than average of
something.
And if that's right,
and that seems likely to be the case,
especially for something like death,
the,
the extra bad of the fact that there's variability and so some people get less
than average.
That extra bad,
I suspect outweighs the extra benefit of some people having more than average.
Well,
consider a different feature.
We've had inevitability,
we had variability,
variability.
What about on predictability?
Not only is it inevitable that you're going to die,
not only do some people live longer than others,
you don't know how much more time you got.
Now you might think,
well,
we didn't.
We already discuss that when we started.
Think about variability,
but in fact,
very logically speaking,
at least variability,
although it's a requirement for unpredictability,
doesn't guarantee unpredictability.
You could have variability with complete predictability.
I imagine that when everybody's born,
you know on on their wrist,
everybody's born with a natural birth mark that indicates the precise year,
day,
and time in which they're going to die.
We could imagine a world like this where it's inevitable.
Everybody has got some date on it,
and for all the Ed for that matter,
there could still be variability.
Some people live 80 years,
some people live 20 years,
but there's no unpredictability because of the the birthmark.
Everybody knows exactly how much longer they've got.
Well,
so in our world,
we don't have that in our world.
Not only do we have variability,
we've got unpredictability.
Does that make things better or does that make things worse?
Would it be better to know when you were going to die?
Well,
one way in which unpredictability at least has the potential of making things
worse.
Is this because you don't know how much more time you got.
You can make a based on statistics,
but in others we saw this wild unpredictability.
You know,
you can take up the average lifespan in the United States is whatever it is,
82 years.
Uh,
so I probably have you guys on your 20 you know,
20 roughly another 60 years ago.
And as you're busy calculator and all this,
you're walking across chapel street and get hit by a truck and you die,
right?
Because of unpredictability,
you can't really know.
And because you can't really know,
it's difficult to make the right kinds of plans.
And in particular,
it's hard to know how to pace yourself.
You know,
you just,
you decide to go off to medical school,
become a doctor.
And so not only do you put the time into college,
you put the time in the medical school and you put the time into your residency
and you put your time into your internship.
And that's a very long commitment.
It's a longterm plan which can go wrong if you get sick and die in your early
twenties
well that's another dramatic example,
but the same sort of thing in principle can happen to all of us.
You,
you,
you make a life plan what you want to accomplish in your life and well obviously
enough,
some of us will die too soon,
not just in terms of,
oh well life still could have had good things but too soon in terms of you
didn't get where you wanted to get in terms of your life plan.
If only you'd known you were only going to have 20 more years instead of 50 more
years,
you would have picked a different kind of life for yourself.
The unpredictability makes it worse
and indeed less.
Obviously it can work the other way as well.
You make a life plan and then you know you don't die yet.
You,
you continue to stick around and the,
and then your life sort of has this feeling of at least we can imagine this
happening,
being sort of anticlimactic.
You sort of,
you peaked too soon.
If only you known you had another 50 years and you weren't going to die young,
you got your James Deane going to burn out fast and die young.
If only you'd realize you were going to live to the ripe old age of 97 you would
have picked a different life for yourself.
Now in thinking about these points in effects,
I'm suggesting that the value of your life,
so you know we previously were talking about different theories of wellbeing and
what makes for a best kind of life.
Here we have yet another kind of feature that we haven't talked about.
We might think of it as the overall shape of your life matters.
The what we could also call the narrative arc of your life matters.
Let me,
let me illustrate the point with some very,
very simple graphs.
These are not meant to be realistic,
but they'll give you the idea so we all know the the Horatio Alger story,
right?
Somebody starts out poor and makes his way through hard work and dedication and
effort to to riches and success,
rags to riches.
That's,
that's a wonderful,
inspiring life.
Let's,
let's draw the graph of that life.
So here's how well off you are.
Here's time.
You start with nothing and you end up incredibly well off.
That's a great life.
That's the Horatio Alger life.
Ha.
Great Life.
All right,
now consider the following story.
Here's axes again.
Yeah,
said the rags to riches life.
Imagine the riches to rags.
Life starts off with everything ends up with nothing.
That's the Algers Horatio's story.
It's the reverse.
Now,
I doubt if there's anybody here who is indifferent between the choices,
the different with regard to the choice between these two lives.
I imagine that everybody here prefers this life.
Okay,
but notice that in terms of the contents of the life,
at least the local contents,
it's a bit hard to see why that would be the case,
right?
You know,
you've got equal periods of suffering and doing slightly better and slightly
better and slightly better equal periods of success and suffering.
You know,
for every bad period here,
there's a corresponding bad period here for every good period here,
there's a corresponding good period here in terms of the contents of your life
being crude.
But you see the point in terms of the contents of your life equally good and
even if we accept the valuable container theory and so we say,
Huh,
you know,
being alive per se is worth something as well.
Well,
you're alive for equal periods of time.
So the extra points get added either way.
Might say,
look,
if we're,
if we're not indifferent between these two lives,
that's because we think the overall shape of your life matters as well.
The narrative arc as I put it,
the story bad to good is the kind of story we want for ourselves.
While the story good to bad is the kind of story we don't want for ourselves.
Interesting question.
Why is that?
And you know this of course should remind us of the puzzle about Lucretia's.
Why do we care more about future nonexistence then pass not existence.
You know when the bad is behind us,
that seems less bothersome than when the bad is in front of us.
You may remember the story from Derek Parfitt about having the painful operation
wasn't going to be in the future.
It wasn't going well.
Did it take place earlier today?
You don't remember.
We're not indifferent.
We want the bad behind us,
not the bad in front of us.
So whatever the explanation is,
we care about the overall shape and trajectory of our life.
Okay.
Now that being the case,
we have to worry then that because of the unpredictability of death that our
lives may not have the ideal shape.
Lot of us might feel that a life like this where we peak,
but then we sort of,
you know,
stick around,
is it Elle can at least fail to be as desirable in which we sort of end with a
bang.
If you start thinking about narrative arcs,
imagine a novel,
right?
It's,
it's one thing to have.
It's not to say that the bay,
if you,
if you want your life to be like the plot of a great story,
it's not as though you think,
all right,
the denouement must occur at the very last page.
So,
okay,
to sort of stick around for a while.
But if,
if the,
if the high point of the story occurs in chapter two and then there's another 67
chapters after that,
you think this was not a well constructed novel and in so far as we care about
the overall shape of our lives,
we might worry about wanting it to have the right shape overall.
Where and when do you want to peak as it were in terms of your accomplishments?
Well,
that matters to us,
but the trouble is without predictability,
you don't know where to put the peak because if you try to aim for peaking
later,
you might not make it to that.
If you put it too soon,
you might stick around for longer than that and then the peak has come too soon.
Yeah.
All of this suggests then that the unpredictability of our death adds an extra
negative element.
It makes it harder to plan what the best way to live my life would be.
And from that perspective it looks as though it would be better to know how much
time you've got left,
but then we have to ask,
so I'll throw the question out.
We'll call it a day start with his next time.
Then we have to ask,
would it really be better to know?
Would you want the birthmark?
Would you want to know exactly how much time you've got left?
Left?
All right.
See you next time.